happy new year everybody this episode of
the honeydew is brought to you by liquid
iv
ritual and raycon more on that later
let's get into the dew
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it
in the night pants studios i am ryan
sickler ryan sickler on all social media
ryan sickler.com i want to thank you
again
uh we're into that next 100 uh plus
episodes and you guys are
you're just awesome thank you so much
for the support and all the love it's
it's felt really good
uh please make sure you don't just watch
on youtube you subscribe on youtube hit
that subscribe button right there
set reminders so you know that you get
video every tuesday
you got the audio coming out on monday
video on tuesday
uh make sure you subscribe to that uh
make sure
you subscribe to the patreon show if you
or someone you know has that story you
know needs to be heard please submit at
honeydewpodcast
gmail.com we'll go through we're going
through
tons of emails now getting you guys on
we have heard some
some fantastic stories so please submit
subscribe to that as well it's five
bucks a month and i do know that
that sixty dollars a year is a lot of
money for some people right now i know
uh we're on unemployment out there a lot
of shit's going on
but if you can't afford it you're in for
the long haul you can save money by
signing up for a year you'll get over a
month of of free episodes
all right social media the facebook fan
page go follow me there the
honeydewpodcast.com is the website
you can get the merch from my website or
the honeydew
we've got the night pants the night
shorts the night pants nation
sweats the coffee mugs the hoodies the
teas it's all there it's great stuff
quality merch
and as always you know i record here at
the santa monica music center so if you
live here in la you need musical
instruments or you want lessons for your
kids
this is the spot you'll get online
classes from local los angeles
musicians and you don't need to live
here you can live around the world maybe
you want to take some music lessons
maybe your kids do right now we're on
this weird [ __ ] hiatus
maybe take a lesson with the kids all
right go to santa monicamusic.com use
the code honeydew
the wave the registration fee i'll give
you one free lesson when you sign up
for a package all right that is the biz
now you know what we do over here we
highlight the low lights i always say
these are the stories behind the
storytellers and uh it's my pleasure to
bring this guy on
first time here on the honeydew with me
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
mazda brownie everyone what's up brian
how are you man
it's good to see you man good to see you
you said you said tuesday
tuesday where you're from where maryland
maryland is that how they talk over
there
way worse than that all right all right
that's a little sample of that
bad day all right all right tuesday i
like that tuesday
um please before i'm excited to talk to
you but before we do plug
promote everything you'd like yeah well
i got my podcast it's called back to
school with mazda obrani like you said
it's on youtube it's on spotify
it's on uh itunes wherever people get
their podcasts back to school with major
we bring in people that are experts in
different fields we learn from them and
we try to make it fun
uh i've had a lot of political people on
recently i just had willie d
from the ghetto boys on really that was
cool man i love the ghetto boys oh
they're great man
how did you get that well that's an
interesting story this week how
this this week halloween fell on this
year halloween fell on a weekend and me
and get to boy so i had heard their
music i knew of them
and if you've ever played the houston
improv willie d's from houston yes he is
so
i had done the show one night and they
said willie d is
in the green room after the show wants
to say hi and i said all right so i'll
go back there
and there he is sitting and it's it's
weird because the the career that you
and i have chosen
we run into people that we've seen right
like if you if you've chosen to be an
accountant it's not like you've seen
some
famous accountant and then one day down
the line you're gonna meet that right
hey try that there he is guys great with
numbers
tax is so good he finishes that [ __ ] on
april 14th
that dude is the [ __ ] man no so there
was none of that there was none of that
and uh and and and and i like meaning
there was no expectation to meet this
person but but you see these people you
go oh there's ice cube oh there's
willy d oh there's champagne oh there
i'm thinking all the people that oh
there's michelle obama i've met all
these people in my life oh yeah
just from doing what we do and so yeah i
come backstage and he's sitting there we
just start talking get to talking and
he's like you know he's he's politically
speaking we're on the same
same wavelength and so we hit it off and
then so every time i go to houston he'll
come check out the show
he actually wanted me to he had he had
some a big like uh i think it was uh
i think it was it was some anniversary
he was doing a roast he wanted me to go
down there and roast him
that was like stressful because i'm not
a big roaster i'm a nice guy
yeah okay i gotta come up with some
stuff and i was like all right willie
you're getting older like instead of
willie d they're gonna call you willie
aarp or something like that
yeah [ __ ] like that but it's funny
because well it's not funny but
unfortunately
the i had to cancel because that's when
not this year but the year before it was
just last year there was fires in like
malibu
and my son had football and his game got
cancelled so then i had to stay here to
watch this game later
and just looking back on it i go god
those seem like simpler times because i
was canceling because of fire
now i can't even i can't even be in a
room yeah yeah it's going
crazy so yeah that's how i met him and
so he came on and and told some good
stories
yeah what um so back to school so you're
getting
knowledge or you get what else would you
get so so i've had listen man i've had
kind of it's kind of like when you have
people come tell the stories you realize
there's so many interesting people with
interesting stories so i had a guy
who helped land the rove mars rover on
mars he worked for
yeah yeah he worked for the jet
propulsion laboratory jpl which is part
of which which was partnered with nasa
and this dude is an iranian-american
guy's name firuz naderi he came and told
the story he goes yeah we've been trying
to land on mars forever
and then he goes we worked on
uh it kept whenever we get into the
atmosphere in mars
the thing would blow up so once they got
the mars rover he goes
it when it went it goes we worked on it
for four years this thing goes all the
way up to mars and he goes
the problem is once these things get
into the atmosphere and mars he goes
it takes eight minutes for the signal to
come back to earth
okay so he goes we knew it had gotten to
mars but we didn't know if it landed
so we get okay it's there now we gotta
wait eight minutes to see if it's landed
and he goes eight minutes go by
and then whoever the mission control
goes you know
rovers landed and he goes i started
crying oh dude i just got
i just got killed so i get chills too he
goes he goes four years we all just
started crying
i'm like holy college eternity right
dude
so there's a guy like that then there's
a lady i brought on who i'd listened to
she was um i forget her name right now
but she had been on um
terry gross uh all things uh not all uh
she does uh fresh air which is an npr
interview show she's great this lady is
a
cave diver like she goes underneath she
goes into caves
i'm already having anxiety but i'm
thinking i've i've gone spill
spelunking before and i wouldn't do that
with water in it [ __ ]
that forget it forget it like swims
underneath finds the pockets and all the
sender
finds the pockets she's the one who like
will do like they'll do ropes as they go
down so they know how to come back and
then it gets dirty and murky underneath
she's the one
leading that like taking the rope down
yeah
yeah and she was telling the story in
her book and her book's amazing her book
talks about like at one point
she and a few other world-class divers
are underneath some
glacier or some [ __ ] and all of a sudden
it starts cracking and it breaks and now
there's
there's current going and it's like
pulling them and they're trying to
use the rope to go back and she's like
the whole time i'm thinking to myself
you know if we get stuck here someone's
got to come save us he goes wait a
minute i realized
the best of the best like we're here
here
who's going to come save us i mean how
crazy is that [ __ ] right
so you hear these stories that sounds
good part of it has been it's been uh
inspirational you know to have these
people on i had a few people on that
rant for congress and for
city council it's just it's it's all
about that so so the whole idea of back
to school with margie majorana came
about because
my kids now are 12 and 9. okay and a few
years ago when they were a little
younger
how old how was your kid six six so you
know how it is you probably get this all
the time
uh hey why is the sky blue hey why is
this how does this work uh
how would you because they think you
know everything you think you know
everything they do and i'm watching this
i'm like [ __ ] i gotta be i would
i would have to be neil degrasse tyson
to have the answers for everything yeah
and then i said you know what i'll start
bringing back
experts and the way we always bring in
experts on my show
and the way our shows always start is i
have my kids on video ask a question
and we edit that in so oh cool yeah so i
had a guy for example this was actually
interesting there's a guy named frank
figluzzi this guy's like
the real deal he's always on msnbc as an
analyst he's the former uh
uh assistant director of the fbi for
counterintelligence
so this dude was all about like he knew
what was going on like he's the
they're the guys who would like look
into like terrorism stuff happening and
all that like what's going on you know
don't leave your house on thursday what
you can't say anything other than that
yeah don't leave your house on thursday
exactly so what i do is i tell my son
i'd be like son
i'll be like dara his name's dara i go
dara the guy coming on is a former fbi
guy i go what's your question for him
he's 12 years old
so he goes okay um i'm going to ask him
if he's ever shot anybody i go that's
probably the right question for a 12
year old dad yes yeah you know yeah so i
asked him if frank actually has a great
answer he's like the truth is in all my
career i didn't have to because he goes
as fbi
uh uh employees he goes we get the
highest kind of training to de-escalate
those things
and that leads into a quick conversation
about this whole
like is it defund the police is it or is
it reimagine the police he goes it's a
reimagining
and he goes if we could spend the
resources that i got
to train me to de-escalate if all our
police force had that
then when you know some homeless guy is
coming at the cop he's not going to
shoot him he's going to know how to
de-escalate that right so it leads to
really interesting stuff yeah
you know so yeah that's been the podcast
been doing it for a little over a year
now with atc
and you and i were just talking about
you know trying to grow it um
so yeah i've been doing so subscribe
subscribe to mazda's podcast subscribe
you go to you go to i have
my youtube channel youtube.com slash
mazzy obrani
uh you what's your social media my
social it's all across the board is at
mazda brawny
and on that too you know how it is man
when this pandemic hit
as comedians i was so busy traveling the
country and the world doing
you travel the world the world yeah and
then all of a sudden people are like oh
no you need to have an online game
and i mean i had online people but all
of a sudden i go wait a minute i thought
online was to promote the live can we
just for a second
going back to when we started way back
whenever
yeah it was just getting up and telling
jokes all i had to do was write jokes
get up and tell them
then it became websites and learning
wordpress and then all of a sudden the
myspaces and the facebooks and the
instagram
and we you don't even see actors having
to do this like
for us as comedians it has been you
better keep up with that [ __ ]
and then podcasting and then podcasting
just used to be audio we'd all be
sitting in each other's living room or
whatever now they're [ __ ] tv shows
it's crazy make sure you subscribe make
sure you subscribe it is crazy because
of what you just said it's like keeping
up with the next thing we all remember
when dane cook
uh hit it big with his myspace page
and i remember him telling me it was
kind of funny because he was like he's
like i get a lot of [ __ ] but
but what do you say he says i'm like uh
he goes he goes but like sometimes when
they give me [ __ ] i'm like
hey man i i i got over a million people
like me or love me or whatever it is
and he goes i can actually literally say
that because he had over a million
people and every and every community was
like how did you do it how'd you do it
well then myspace goes away and then
facebook comes on and then facebook goes
away and then
instagram as you said it's like constant
not that tick tock i haven't even gotten
it i know
i got an account but i didn't do nothing
i didn't do anything with it no because
i'm like i don't know but but in the
meantime the one thing that i've that
i've
learned a little bit in this pandemic is
i used to think okay instagram was like
okay put your
three minute video so people will go
watch the full video
but somebody was telling me they're like
no no instagram's his own thing now so
you gotta put the video you got on
instagram is the video that you need to
have on instagram
don't mess with having people go oh now
go and put this url and go over here
of course you put it in there but people
want to be and then i was like you know
what that's kind of how i do it too like
i get
if i get videos i just watch watch watch
and then i stop
yeah so what is this constantly learning
constantly switching you and i was just
talking
about this whole like then there's
patreon then there's this and there's
and i'm like oh my god it's overwhelming
i know it's a lot of [ __ ] so look
i want to get into this because i want
to know more about you
and your background i know we're going
to talk about your grandfather yes but
grandfathers always start
down the line yeah so talk to me a
little bit about your family your
and then you know your upbringing let's
get into your grandfather real quick is
this your dad's dad or my mom's dad my
mom
so first of all before i go any further
too also if people want to like get
an idea of my comedy stuff i do have the
netflix special
called immigrants so they can check that
out um and i talk a lot about being an
immigrant because i was an immigrant so
this is a great
lead-in to what i am i am an immigrant
so born in iran in 1972
and 78 protests start in the streets of
iran against the shah of iran he was the
king basically
and um up until then a lot of people had
they've been protests they've been
unrest and and the shah
being a dictator at the time um
now you know granted uh you could call
him like a benevolent dictator as well
because
he did he he modernized the country in
many ways so he brought a lot of good to
the country but at the same time
he had a secret police that would
disappear people so it's kind of like
you know what i'm saying yeah depending
on what side you're on right yeah right
he's a good guy if you're good yeah yeah
good and by the way the government that
comes after him which is the islamic
republic of iran
is they they they take away all that
modernization
and they pull people back and they
disappear a lot more people so they're
even
they're even more atrocious but let's
get back to the show so the shaw
had been good at uh quashing
these types of uprisings so i think in
the late 70s a lot of people didn't
think
that a revolution was going to happen so
my father's on business
in america um in new york and he tells
my mom hey why don't you bring
so at the time it's me my older sister
miriam and my
baby brother kashi at the time and my uh
and you're how old at this point at that
point i'm six years old okay 78
late 70. my dad says hey listen it's a
winter break
two-week winter break why don't you
bring me and my older sister
come to new york stay with me for a
couple weeks and then you guys can go
back and by then hopefully the protest
will have calmed down and
and i always say this is a common story
for a lot of iranians you know we come
here and the protests get
more and more and more so i would say we
packed for two weeks and we stayed for
40 something years
let me ask you this real quick this is
my own ignorance outside of
coming to the u.s where's another
popular destination people would flee
from iran and go where else that's a
great question so um i think because now
you got to realize
iran similar to countries like let's say
india or um countries like uh um
i'm trying to think other uh countries
where like
other like there's places like um
i'm not sure pakistan will fall into it
basically a lot of these countries have
had
western influence right so india
obviously had the british
the british running it for a long time
you know or this this is a good idea
like like uh you know a lot like algeria
in those places had the french
right so iran at some point it had some
french influence but for the most part
through the 1900s like starting from the
mid
night like in 1953 just to go back for a
second
iran had a guy who was democratically
elected his name was mossad
this guy was the parliamentary leader
who was elected as that
the shah who later ends up in the
revolution in the late 70s
um he was the king but the people had
elected this guy so it was parliament
and then there was the king
now the west england and the us
wanted the shot in power because the
shah would let the u.s and england have
oil interests i see this guy mo sadek
when he took over he tells the british
he goes hey
british petroleum you've been taking our
oil for all these years
we're going to nationalize our oil and
take our oil back so the brits go to the
americans and they go hey
if this guy is able to do that then iran
will go to the russians and it'll become
communist
so they play the communist card in the
50s and eisenhower
says all right let's do this and and
there's a guy named kermit roosevelt
who's like the grandson of
one of the roosevelt like teddy
roosevelt or something he helps lead
the cia coup that overthrows the
democratically elected leader
as a matter of fact years later i think
bill clinton apologized for because
for the long time america was like oh we
didn't do it we didn't do it but it's
one of the only
i mean we live in a time of conspiracy
it's one of the only
coups that went the way they planned it
to go
because the fact is when you try to do a
lot of this stuff human
human emotions and errors get involved
and they don't it doesn't go the way you
wanted to go this went the way they
wanted to go they they brought
cia operatives into the streets of iran
who were saying this guy is a communist
communist and then they overthrow that
guy and then the shah
is in place from 53 to 78 basically
those 20-something years
shaw is allowing the west to have its
oil and he's buying he's taking that oil
money and buying weapons from america so
it's like win-win for the
right weapons and oil industry so
um all of that to say uh um uh uh
your your question was i i got what
other countries would
people oh yeah yeah so all that to say
so so so iranians
were iranians would go some went to
england
like london um some went to paris
okay now you gotta realize the people
who
fled in the late 70s were the ones who
had the money to do it so they were
successful under the shah
and when this islamic republic comes in
they go
full-on like stalin you know executions
so they go oh
if you were part of the shah's
government
we're hanging you so they started
hanging people and this is again late
70s right 79 ayatollah khomeini comes in
right and they go like it goes full-on
cult of personality
women's rights get somebody there's a
there's a female
uh um so wait they had women had more
rights under
the other under the shaw really yeah so
under the shot under the shop
even though there was political like he
he was he did not allow political
dissent
like in a democratic country where you
could go oh hey this president sucks
well if you wrote an op-ed piece this
pres you know the shah sucks
someone knock on your door and be like
come talk to us right
and and so there was a lot of that going
on but that said he'd also
westernized and modernized the country
so there's videos and pictures of iran
in the 70s
women got their mini skirts on they're
dancing they're going to discontext
there's all kinds of stuff happening
um there's like there's there's you know
iranians are very proud people so
there's like
old videos of when elizabeth taylor and
richard burton went to visit iran that
kind of stuff
so there's a there's a human rights
activist her name is shirin abadi who
who won a nobel peace prize years ago
she's this tiny little lady i think
she's a lawyer
she made a she made a good statement she
goes the islamic revolution was not
a revolution it wasn't so much an
islamic revolution as it was
against a a a a a woman's
opposition revolution because all of a
sudden a lot of rights that women had
went the other way so all of a sudden
women had to cover themselves
before that you didn't have the coverage
i'm sitting here thinking about that now
like imagine being a woman then who
could wear a miniskirt and all of a
sudden you got to cover yourself
you got to cover yourself at what
penalty at the penalty of you know it
became
pretty i mean you're going to jail if if
you're out in the street it got dark
it got pretty dark so they had like uh
um um you know
morality police who would go around
there's actually uh
if people are into it there's a there's
a great graphic novel this lady wrote
her name is marjan satrapi she is a
french iranian
and she's one of these like
intellectuals where's the turtleneck
smoke cigarettes
so she wrote she wrote a two-part
uh um uh graphic novel that got turned
into a
graphic uh film is called persopolis
as persopopos one persopless two because
what happens is you know i i love
whenever i read any books about history
or whenever you see a documentary about
history go oh my god i can't believe
that happened and then that happened
right so for example just a quick side
note
i was watching something recent i forget
what it was some documentary and it was
talking about how
barack obama the day when gay marriage
was legalized
was also the day when they had the
i think it was the funeral for was it
south carolina where that guy went into
the black church
i think it was i think it was around the
same time when barack goes up and he
starts singing and they all these black
church
leaders starting to stand up and they
start singing with him and
whatever the documentary was was talking
about how
he had to go do that then he comes back
to the white house and the white house
is
lights are rainbow colors and michelle
obama says i got the girls and i was
like
tell the secret service screw you we got
to go this is history because people
i don't remember people people converged
on the white house to celebrate so she's
like i had to take the kids to watch it
and i go oh my god can you imagine
within the same day
you got this and you know murder
mass murder and then you got this
beautiful you know open
freedom freedom yeah so when you go back
and look at a lot of this stuff you go
wow i can't believe this led to this
so here you have the iranian revolution
people flee like my
my father was successful under the shah
um but he wasn't
part of the you know he you know he
wasn't part of his administration or
anything so
but my father had enough money to flee
so he flees and then the ayatollah
khomeini so shaw leaves in the early 70s
like
january or something february ayatollah
khomeini comes in
he becomes like again if you want to you
know historical figures
it's a cult of personality right so he's
this
religious leader that you know a lot of
the people that are religious who are
poorer
love and look up to and so once he comes
in
and he basically is like well we don't
need all these like intellectuals and
people
they're they don't need these people
like these people that were um
successful in the show we don't let the
doctors leave let them all get out of
here
not realizing like you're gonna need
these people right yeah and then
quickly it turns dark you get the
morality police you get people getting
executed you get
women's rights being pulled back and
right around that same time saddam
hussein is like oh there's turmoil in
this country
let me because they're on the iraq and
iran are neighbors
so saddam's like let me take advantage
of this and try and get some of this
oil like region that he wanted that had
been in conflict for a while that had
been in dispute
i think he goes to get it and then that
leads to the iran-iraq war
that then goes for another seven eight
years
and khomeini in his mind i've read
about this a little bit where they say
that he thought okay
this revolution is going to spread
around the region like we're going to
spread our revolution
and sorry to get really inside baseball
with this but
the iran is the main shiite country
shiite islam saudi arabia is the main
sunni islam so it's like protestant and
catholic right
but iran's neighbor iraq was majority
shiite
so they have the same kind of religion
but it was being run by a sunni saddam
hussein
so i think romanian is going well if
these guys have a majority shiite we are
the biggest shiite countries our
neighbor
we should spread our our revolution
should go here and we should kind of
we should own this area so he goes into
war
with the er with iraq being confident of
course
millions of people like millions of
young people die literally in this iraq
uh iraq iran war it got to the point
where first of all america going back to
the us and military
but real quick can i ask all this is
going on while you guys are
on this break this was this is the first
two weeks of it but then but then like
within the next
year the war didn't happen the first two
weeks right but this is
the unrest is starting and everything we
come to america and we see
we see oh wow this revolution is
happening romani's there oh wow
and by the way there's another thing
that i haven't put in here yet but it
gets crazier
this is what happens so late so late 70s
becoming america
79 khomeini comes shah leaves khomeini
comes
shaw is persona non grata like the
iranians go we want him we want to
execute him
now that it's like you know how they
kill saddam the iranians that took over
the islamic republic they were like we
want the shah
because we want to execute for all the
crimes we're going to put him up against
if they're going to execute them
well the shah was allies with
egyptian anwar sadat he was allies with
the u.s
and it turns out the shah has cancer so
he's fled his country
and he's got cancer and then he goes so
a lot of countries go we don't want
you because your own country's
like want you there and this could be
trouble for us
like they could cause some kind of
problems well first the egyptian anwar
sadat goes hey we're buddies come stay
here for a little while he goes stays
there for a while
then his cancer is getting worse so
jimmy carter at the time says come stay
here new york sloan kettering i think it
was the sloan kettering cancer institute
of course that's when the iranians go
well
we don't want trouble but we want the
shah you guys are you guys have the shah
so you know what we're going to do some
iranian students go we're going to go
take americans hostage from the american
embassy
so the hostage crisis happens so it goes
revolution hostage crisis leads nicely
into this war iran iraq war where
millions of people die
where america is selling arms both to
the iraqis and the iranians
we were selling arms on both sides so it
just gets messier and messier millions
of people die
hostage crisis is probably the one
that's closer to in my mind because
when the hostage crisis happens similar
to everything we see in this country
anytime any country or anybody does
anything like coronavirus right all of a
sudden you got these
these these knuckleheads going china
virus you know and like hey
kung flu i mean in this case it's the
president but there's a lot of people do
that i was gonna say knuckleheads that
was the price
but that's the thing the problem is like
these guys don't realize that there's
gonna be some [ __ ]
at a traffic light gonna turn over and
see some like
south korean guy has no idea what korean
and even if the guy were chinese he
didn't cause the goddamn
corrodifier they're gonna yell at him
this is not gonna happen you go back to
your country kung fu whatever you know
i'm saying so
similarly when the hostage crisis
happens
people start picking on iranians and
i've had other friends like ahmed ahmed
would tell me he's egyptian he's like
yeah people used to call me [ __ ]
iranian so back then they would call you
[ __ ] iranian they'd beat you up
so you would you'd be bullied here in
new york no no no no
at this point i've moved to we've gone
from new york to marine county northern
california
great uh and you're how old now i'm like
at this point uh
so probably like seven eight so it was
like i think that i think the
hostage crisis happened end of 79 so i'm
probably seven or eight years old
and you're going now to from new york
city to
what i'm thinking is a very white region
oh definitely well first of all first of
all new york city for me
i'll tell you what the interesting thing
is since i was six years old we moved
when we came to new york
came for two weeks and stayed stayed but
but but for a short time
my father was a successful businessman
so he was staying at the plaza hotel in
a suite
so it was my sister and i playing all
day my dad's doing his business
fao shorts biggest toy store in the
world is across the street
my mom's taking us shopping i love the
color orange because as a kid in iran
um because we were very westernized like
i had like muhammad ali dolls i had
spiderman
but one of my favorite colors was the
color orange because we had
similar to the fanta orange drink we had
a canada dry made an orange drink
okay that was my that was my thing so i
come to america
my mom takes me to macy's and it's and
by the way
going back and looking at it that winter
was one of the
coldest winters in recent history in new
york
so it's super cool my mom takes me to
macy's and i get a snoopy
hat glove and scarf set that's orange
okay i'm like this
and i'm sitting there as a kid i'm like
this is fantastic we go you know i get
to go upstairs to the plaza hotel get
strawberry ice cream with whipped cream
cartoons in iran like you might have had
like a half an hour cartoons come to
america already even back then
you got hours and hours of cartoons all
day so like the revolution was working
out for me you know what i'm saying
it's so bad yeah so i do i do basically
i do like we're there for about a month
and that's when my dad goes well let's
find a house cause we're living in a
hotel let's find a house so we started
looking but it's so cold
my mom says to my dad listen you know
let's let's get out of here
this is too cold here and now years
later when my mom and dad split up and
divorced my father would be like you
know your mom screwed me over because
back then there was a building in
midtown i was going to buy it it's worth
150 million dollars
i'm like i don't know dad i don't know
what to do yeah all right what do you
want me to tell you yeah
you might have been a little bit i had a
snoopy skull yeah you're probably drunk
so you didn't know what you're doing
um so so my dad
was you know the best character to
compare my dad to and i've always wanted
to do a movie
based on him is um he was like vito
corleone and godfather
in that in the in his community if you
wanted something done
he'd take care of it and he was very
generous and and i always thought it was
like stories i heard until when he
passed away i had friends of his come up
and be like
hey i got to tell you something man if
it weren't for your dad i never would
have been able to leave the country
really straight up i've had two or three
people straight up tell me their stories
one guy was like an admiral in the navy
he escaped he was living in texas
with his british wife and my dad was
like
sent him plane tickets in texas and my
dad was able to bring his money out so
he's like sending him plane tickets like
in my and the way my dad would do his
business is because there's a lot of
pride in our community
and so somebody if i say to you hey ryan
you know let me let me buy this car for
you like you're supposed to be like no
no no even if you're
suffering no no so the way my dad would
do it he'd be like look i'm sending you
plane
tickets you have two options you either
get on it and come and our
friendship remains or ignore it and then
never call me again you're out of my
life like you put that kind of pressure
on these people
so the guy's like your dad said just get
away come out stay with us so
the guy comes to stay with us when we're
in marin and then this guy wrote a book
about it tells a story and he goes
one day my dad's like come on i gotta go
to the bank do some business so we go he
goes my dad takes his friend of the bank
and he goes this is in like 1980 or
something he's like he writes it takes a
check out for 10 grand
and he goes he hands it to me and he
goes take this
he goes now you know pay me back when
you can
but just i know where you are and i can
do i can afford this and
he makes them take it again and and the
guy goes that that helped me like get my
life back together over here so my dad
was doing that kind of stuff a lot
um uh so sometimes through the detriment
by the way he would buy
anytime any friend had something they
didn't need my dad would buy it
so my dad would like one time he comes
home with a rolls royce
what yeah we're like what's this and
he's like oh so-and-so couldn't afford
it so i just bought it off
yeah yeah i swear to god i swear to god
[ __ ] my eyes it's
you know and i have no idea how that
like transaction went down like
you know yeah i'm sure the guy was like
look man
yeah so and here's the funny thing is
because you would think you would think
that oh
that must've been cool to be in a rose i
hated it like i hated it because
i was already like getting picked on for
like being an oil rich kid
yeah tell me about that yeah so so i'm
so so the hostage crisis happens
and people start calling you [ __ ]
iranian and all that stuff and i have
some friends that are getting beaten up
more than others and i've talked to
people now
30 40 years later who go oh yeah man
there was death threats there was all
kinds of stuff like people were
losing their minds similar to what
happened like after september 11th
remember
yeah of course they were shooting indian
sikhs just because they had turbans
yes right so there was a guy in the
sixth grade and i got i i really hope i
get this
i remember this right because i vaguely
remember this guy he would
you know these guys were kind of like
bullies i was in fourth grade
so they would call you [ __ ] iranian
you know um
and you know i was not a
uh i was not a smart ass you know so i
think i kind of
either kind of took it or i
or i just kind of like laughed it off or
whatever but i had a friend of mine
who was this ironic american kid who
like was like joe pesci he liked to
fight
so this guy would get picked on and
beaten up all the time and i'd be like
dude you got to stop talking [ __ ]
you know but that was the the the the
era we were in
and um looking back i remember like
the year before in the third grade i got
i got some kind of fight a scuffle like
i haven't gotten too many fights in my
life i got to fight
on a playground and i remember like the
bell rang and me and this guy were still
fighting and i know
i could swear that must have started
from you know
kids are gonna be like oh camel jockey
or some [ __ ] like that right
and i don't know what i'm doing i'm just
there you know and the the the things
that got me through were i was a good
athlete so like come kickball time i
could hold my own
um and i used to also i had a sweet
tooth and i'd go shopping with my mom
and she'd buy like a bag
she buy a cart of food that we need and
i had a cart of like just junk food
and then i'd go to school with one bag
that had a sandwich drink and a snack
and another bag that had like starbursts
and milky way i'd be handing that [ __ ]
out i'd be bribing my way into
friendships you know
so those two things plus i think i i
think that's where i i
started to because i'd watch a lot of
cartoons you know and i don't know how
it was for you we're about the same age
i'm 40 and i'm probably older than you
but in our era our parents weren't like
let's go outside and play cash let's go
for a hike
they were working or doing whatever the
[ __ ] they could sit you down in front of
the tv and watch this [ __ ]
that was it so i think that's kind of
where i got my g.i
joe hey man what do you would pack what
do you want
all of them i think i got my uh uh
interest in comedy probably around yeah
and then i would start doing voices and
[ __ ]
and now i'm in school trying to be funny
and i think all of that combined
comedy bribery of candy and
athleticism led to me being able to like
just deflect
yeah deflect and get through that [ __ ]
you know let's take a quick break and
tell you about our first sponsor liquid
iv now if there's one thing we can all
agree on it's that 2020 was rough
now it's time to clean the slate and
start 20 21
off on the right foot one goal i have
for myself this year
is to stay hydrated i'm doing that with
the help of my favorite hydration
product
liquid iv with one stick of liquid iv in
16 ounces of water you get two to three
times the amount of hydration
as plain water liquid iv has incredible
hydration flavors like watermelon lemon
lime and passion fruit
and they recently launched strawberry
now imagine a freshly picked taste of
ripe juicy strawberries topped with
decadent notes of whipped cream it's
amazing
all right here's what i love about
liquid iv i'm using them
i use them a couple times a day i wake
up in the morning boom glass of water
throw some liquid iv in there i love the
tangerine one that's my favorite so far
but they're all good um i know friends
that are using them right now for
hangovers they feel great after that
there are days i go out for a walk
whatever come back boom just have one
stay hydrated it makes you feel so much
better i don't get the headaches i was
having
you know it contains five essential
vitamins and more vitamin c
than an orange and as much potassium as
a banana
it's healthier than sugary sports drinks
there's no artificial flavors or
preservatives and less sugar than an
apple
it's made with clean ingredients non-gmo
vegan and free of gluten dairy and
soy it's the perfect balance to help you
hydrate more quickly
and effectively than water alone and the
company is donating 3.7 million servings
in response to coven 19. the products
are being donated
to hospitals first responders food banks
veterans and active military liquid iv
has donated over 6.7 million servings
globally liquid iv is available
nationwide at costco
or you can get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com
and use the code honeydew at checkout
that's 25
off of anything you order when you use
the promo code honeydew at liquidive.com
get better hydration today at
liquidity.com
promo code honeydew our next sponsor is
raycon now every new year all you hear
is new year new me that usually means
you'll be picking up better habits or
trying new things and if you do take up
a new hobby it's even better when you
have amazing audio that will make
the experience that much more enjoyable
that's why i recommend wireless earbuds
for raycon
you've been hearing me talk about raycom
for a while i absolutely use them i
absolutely believe in them
so whether it's following along to
directions in the kitchen
or binging an audio book while learning
to knit or powering through a new
workout with a pumped up playlist in
your ear or checking out the honeydew
just while you do your stuff around the
house a pair of raycons
can make any activity easier and a
better time
raycon makes great sound accessible to
everyone their wireless earbuds start at
half the price
of other premium audio brands and guess
what if you think having white stems
dangling out of your ears looks
ridiculous
that's something you don't have to worry
about with raicons they come in a range
of stylish colorways but
always with a comfortable in-ear fit for
a more discreet look and they don't just
look great raycons perform wherever you
take them
with up to six hours of playtime water
and sweat resistant
construction and bluetooth that pairs
quickly
and seamlessly you've heard me say all
this before so if you still don't have a
pair of raycons
i really gotta wonder why i bought them
i bought at least three or four pair for
christmas this year and everyone already
loves them
they're not going to be using any other
wireless earbuds raycon's offering
15 off of all their products for my
listeners and here's what you got to do
to get it you go to buy raycon.com
honeydew that's it you'll get 15 off
your entire
raycon order so feel free to grab a pair
and a spare
that's 15 off at byraycon.com
honeydew by raycon.com honeydew
our next sponsor is ritual now do you
really know what's in your multivitamin
i don't i look stuff up online i ask
people i've heard sawdust
stuff to make yoga mats out of i don't
know
sugars gmos synthetic fillers artificial
color it's not to mention animal
byproduct like
sheep's wool and gelatin from hooves and
hides
they're all ingredients you might find
in a multivitamin that sounds disgusting
but ritual isn't your typical
multivitamin rituals clean
vegan-friendly formulas made with key
nutrients
forms your body can actually use all
right no
shady extras like i'm telling you i
wanted to start taking a new
multivitamin i've been looking for new
vitamins
and i read all this stuff that's garbage
in where you buy them in
in the store and when i got this offer i
was like man i'm telling you i've been
looking for something like this i was
really happy to get rich on board
it's a multivitamin reimagined all right
it's formulated with
nutrients including vitamin d3 to help
fill gaps in the diet
their fresh tasting delayed release
capsules are designed to dissolve later
in less sensitive areas of the stomach
so you can take them with or without
food that's the other thing i make my
daughter take vitamins every day
on a full stomach because i told her you
take vitamins on an empty stomach it'll
put you in the hospital
now available for women men and teens
ritual vitamins
are scientifically developed to help
support different life stages ritual
makes healthy habits easy
your multivitamins are delivered to your
door every month with free shipping
always you can start
snooze or cancel your subscription at
any time and if you don't love ritual
within your first month they'll refund
your first order you deserve to know
what's in your multivitamin that's why
rituals offering my listeners 10
off during your first three months visit
ritual.com
honeydew to start your ritual today
that's ritual.com
honeydew now let's get back to the duke
so where
what sort of role was your grandfather
playing in your life at this point
is he is he in america so that's so here
so here's the thing with my dad so my
dad goes from
he goes from new york he's got a friend
in reno so my dad being the
veto coordinator type he also liked to
gamble a lot we go to reno because his
friend's like hey
marina come here my dad goes to reno and
uh he's like oh we're gonna save the mgm
grand we get a suite there
my dad he's like a whale when it comes
to gambling so he's you know he's going
at it and every time every hotel we went
to i sort of got ryan
my mom would be like yeah your dad's
thinking of buying this place mgm grain
you want to buy the mgm
i certainly got i'm not kidding man this
is like real [ __ ]
my dad my dad everywhere there was there
was another hotel called cal neva lodge
on the border of
california nevada in lake tahoe he's
flying on the plane with the owner he's
like i think i'm gonna buy
he was like that guy so when my dad's
there
he's gambling so much they give us free
sweets free everything you go ahead and
gamble your life away just stay for free
so then he calls a friend of his
who's living in marin he goes bring your
family i got rooms for you guys so they
all come out
then that friend says why don't you come
to marin and hang with us for a minute
so we end up in marin
and that's where my dad's like oh i love
it up here so he gets a house near there
and
that's where i grew up and so my father
was again being the kind of guy he was
so it's my dad my mom at the time
uh me my sister we get my baby brother
my baby brother stayed in iran and had
to come out like a year later
with our nanny so they come out then my
mom's pregnant
my youngest brother is born in 1979
and then my dad works on bringing
relatives out right so he brings my
mom's mother out first um then he brings
then years later
my mom's father his name was akbar like
you know the akbar there's an akbar and
silverlight yeah so akbar means um
great so they say allah akbar means god
is great
okay and my grandfather wasn't religious
my grandfather was um
he was he was ahead of his time he's
like he's our mahatma gandhi in our in
my world
he was very uh very much a
humanitarian very much an intellectual
and this dude was something else so he
owned
he owned a carpet store carpet business
in iran in the bazaars
so just to take you back to that
revolution and you know we've seen it
here now right like like when you have
protests
or you have on you know none of us know
if we're on the right side of history
until history happens and then we go oh
[ __ ]
i should never have yeah right right
about that yeah
you know you never know you never know i
mean hopefully you get a chance to know
dude give it five ten years then you'll
see my my grandfather when that
revolution happened in iran in the
bazaar so so what had happened was
because the shah
had created so many of some so many
enemies even though he'd modernize a
country
he had enemies that were the religious
group that ended up taking over in the
end
the muslim the the the mullahs he had
um let's say like um the liberal
you know intellectuals who felt like we
don't have our freedoms
he had all these different groups well
when the revolution happens
it you can't just have the like two
segments you got to get like almost the
whole country's got to get to a point
where they revolt so
my grandfather was part of what's called
the bazaris there's bazaars in iran
every city's got a bazaar
it's like it's like a farmer's market on
steroids okay so my grandfather's
my aquarius stores were in the bazaars
and so
when the buzzaris stepped up because
that's a big part of the
economy when they stepped up and they
said during the protests that led to the
to the fall of the shah
they stepped and said we're going to
close our stores and protest of
some of the things that the shah has
been doing that's when the revolution
really started like all of a sudden
you would have these protests originally
the protests were just like people that
were
against the shah then it was like the
bizarres it was bizarre doctors lawyers
professionals now you got millions of
people
that's when the shop was like i'm done
i'm out so my grandfather
when these protests happened my
grandfather supported the protesters
and the reason was because he was you
know uh
um idealistic in his mind he goes well
these young people
are uh um you know they want a better
life
because what happened was under the shah
similar to what we're going through
right now
the rich were getting richer the poor
were not
and so these people that were taking
over promise well
we will distribute the wealth to
everybody which they never did of course
are dirtier than anybody but my
grandfather was saying when he when he
saw these young people protesting he was
out there being like oh here's some food
or whatever
go get you know like good for you you
know but quickly when he saw
khomeini comes in and he sees that this
regime comes in
and they start um executing
and they start taking away rights my
grandfather couldn't help himself it was
vocal so he's like i'm in the bazaar
cussing out khomeini and my grandfather
could cuss like the cussing he would do
it was like
it was comical he'd be like maya you
know who says he's he'd be like
i wish like i wish a cow would have like
[ __ ] romania's
mother in the asteroids [ __ ] out of that
[ __ ] out and so
some like some some pro khomeini types i
mean imagine like
imagine if if under the trump
administration let's say it got
more and more extreme and let's say all
of a sudden all
the press had been silenced and let's
just say like it got to that point
let's say all of a sudden all the
extreme right was
suddenly on board and took over this
country let's just say unless it was
it was religious based then imagine
somebody in the middle of a
town square going like [ __ ] trump or
whatever well
those people are going to come get them
oh yeah so my grandfather was yelling
things
in public and some people were like this
dude's gonna
get it get it so that's when my dad was
like we gotta we gotta extract
your mother's father get his ass out of
there
so they couldn't shut him up so they
moved his ass
yeah so you bring your grandfather or
your dad brings your grandfather over
how old is he when he comes
here so here's the thing so my
grandfather's my grandfather passes away
in 2003.
and the truth is given the fact that he
was born in 1903 we
we think whoa he lived to a hundred you
lived to a hundred holy [ __ ] yeah so we
think he was
gonna take a lot longer than i thought
he would yeah oh [ __ ] oh yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah no no he lived he looked good
he we think he was 9800 we lost we
didn't have his birth certificate so
we'd be like how old are you he's like i
don't know like 97 i'm not sure
i used to do a joke about that i said
every once in a while i used to say we
said i said every once in a while we
just throw his
throw his like a a candle on a cake for
during someone else's birthday we'd be
like hey grandpa you blow it up too yeah
sometimes we do it twice a year be like
i'm aging fast this year like i ended up
with two birthdays
so so he was probably so if he comes out
in let's say oh god i don't even
remember when it was let's say it was
like
mid-80s so we're talking like uh
20 years so maybe he was in his maybe he
was in his like 80s or late
mid to late 70s you know or low 80s
and he comes he lives with us and this
dude what was amazing about him was
he had a work ethic man so he used to
the bazaar
having a rug store is like you're
constantly folding those rugs putting
them away all that
this dude could not sit still he was not
at all one of these like
old people who just sat on a chair and
was like give me my you know
drink first of all he didn't drink or
smoke every once in a while i'd be like
give me a ketila he called tequila
and he would wake up every morning
because he's from an era
in iran when like men used to dress up
again like the godfather they put on a
fedora they put on a suit sometimes a
three-piece suit it's funny even here
you go back to the black and white days
uh it's funny you watch the sporting
events from the 50s these people are in
the stands and suits yeah
they're flying in suits now we're flying
in underwear and panties on our face and
[ __ ]
yeah i've been wearing the same pants
for nine months i have not had jeans on
since this started dude
you throw covet in with what the casual
world we live in right now
and every time people be like well steve
jobs used to go to work in jeans i was
like all right well i'm going to work in
underwear yeah um so yeah
he uh he comes out here and he can't sit
still so
he just becomes like you know he would
wake up every morning
at like six or seven in the morning does
he live with you he was living with him
okay he was living with us so he became
so first of all my mom at the time did
not cook so my grandfather would be
cooking
he'd wake up every morning like six or
seven in the morning make some breakfast
get into his suit and be like all right
what am i doing today and then every day
come up with he create his own
uh agenda every day be like okay i think
that
these cupboards here need to all be
cleaned
and you know you take the plates out
clean the plates put them all back in
they'd be like okay uh today i'm gonna
go shopping and he didn't speak english
that's what i wanted to ask how did he
take to being here did he enjoy it
he was you know he was just he got
around without speaking english yeah he
was an amazing human being so first we
were in marin with each other
and then i think he liked moving down to
la because marin it was a
suburbs so he needed to have people
drive him here and there
but in in la especially in westwood la
has the biggest population of iranians
outside of iran is that right yeah
i didn't know that yeah yeah so so
whereas in in la when i would run into
i'm sorry in marin if i ran into an
iranian it was an event i'd be like
oh my god who's your dad oh my god hey
yeah you know down here
it's like especially in westwood you'd
run hey you're running they'd be they've
got to be like yeah so is everybody like
what do you think
yeah i swear to god westwood boulevard
is that why
that stretch of wilshire with those me
those beautiful condos and all is that a
is that an iranian community
yeah the golden mile there there's a lot
there's some of those buildings are just
mostly persians wow and there's a lot of
persian jews that live there
as well as in beverly hills and then
there's a lot of persian muslims that
live i knew some celebrities had condos
in there and stuff but i always wondered
what the hell everybody else did in that
little corner they brought their money
from that country
yeah yeah and they bought property a lot
about property
yeah yeah so my grandfather i think what
he liked about westwood was
he would he'd be able to walk in into
town and there was a couple of stores
he'd go hang out and like
do his shopping but he would also hang
out and like you know sing for the guy
and tell poetry back in the day think
about this
storytelling like back in the day
there's a persian tradition they would
it was kind of like um it was kind of
like uh rap battles
but it was with poetry and so you and i
would sit like to entertain themselves
they would sit there and be like
he who goes farthest is not the thing
he'd be like yeah but he who did
and they'd go back and forth so they had
he had poems memorized
like forever and ever their brains were
working man so he would go and he had
songs that he that he knew and he had
like poems so he'd go to like
some of these stores persian like
grocery stores and he'd just go buy his
[ __ ] and then he just hang out and talk
to the store owner and be like
somebody would come in the guy would
ring him up and then they would all the
conversation would keep going so he'd be
gone for hours
he loved it and and but what was amazing
about him though was
again being kind of a humanitarian like
he would make
friends just by doing look he's bored to
death
right so i remember one time we were
living in marin there was like
some construction site about like a mile
away
and my grandfather was like come on uh
give me give me a ride i gotta do
something i'm like what he's like
next thing you know he goes to the
kitchen picks up a pot and pan he's been
cooking
and he brings and he brings the stuff in
the car down to the construction site
and the dude some american guy is like
hey your grandfather keeps bringing us
lunch he was just making lunch
making lunch with these guys working
he's like here you go man
random comments they loved him they knew
him everybody knew him he was like oh we
love this guy
yeah he's like what's up yes yes thank
you you know he was speaking
english you know it's crazy could you
imagine i can't imagine living in
another country where i don't speak the
language you're just showing up in the
construction site with like pizza
that's the thing he just was like let's
do it he's like let's just do it that is
great you could do that
like and and it's funny because my mom
he used to call he used to say my mom is
stingy because my mom was
a little little not not as generous as
him um
so so one time like when we live in l.a
and this is again
whatever it was late 90s at this point
he
he took some like blankets that we had
at the house and he took him down the
street he'd seen a homeless person so he
went over and was like here's some
blankets
they told me he's like don't tell your
mom she's gonna get pissed off that i
gave away the blankets
and i'm like i mean just like do you man
and that's the guy he was
um and people knew him and he was like
so he was very much like
you know he he would teach his lessons
like he you know
things that i remember to this day he
would say i remember
because again he was not a lazy person
at all
i mean i'll tell you ryan like like for
example again when we were in tiburon
in in marin um i don't know what
happened
one of my dad's friends gave my dad like
a bunch of he either gave it to him or
yeah it was it was a bunch of like big
pieces of tree trunks we had a fireplace
so he's like hey here's these tree tree
trunks if you want to use it for your
fireplace
so they're sitting there in the backyard
and
my grandfather was like all right so
what now and i'm like well we gotta get
someone
to cut this [ __ ] up so they get he's
like get somebody's like
you are the someone yeah so i'm like
what are we gonna do he's like well we
gotta get it we gotta get a salt
i mean you know so next thing i know i'm
at a place called big four rents
renting a chainsaw i've never worked a
chainsaw i'm 14 15 years old
you know i'm a teenager i don't want to
be doing i'd rather be like masturbating
or something yeah for real he's like
let's go
to this place let's get the rental and
we'll do it none of us knows how to do
this
but we do it so there i am with a chance
of just
cutting wood that's the kind of guy he
was let's get it done one time it got
him in trouble cause
he goes in the backyard all these leaves
have fallen he just without telling us
he's over there
sweet i mean he will find things to do
every day sweep sweep sweep
next thing you know we're all sitting at
the house and we're here
we look outside fire trucks what's going
on we look in the backyard he started a
fire
he burned him he's trying to burn the
leaves not realizing you can't i eat
kisses yeah he's like back in the old
country he could do this [ __ ]
so that's the kind of guy he was man and
he told me like one time like he was
like
you know sitting in the living room and
and he's like hey could you give me a
glass of water and i was like sure sure
and i went off to do something else you
know a couple minutes later he's like
where's that water i was like oh i was
doing something i'd get it for he's like
listen man he's like in life if you say
yes
just do it he goes because the person
who asks for the water they want that
water so he goes you can
either say yes or say no but if you tell
somebody yes
then do it right away and do it like
like get it done with pride and i was
like damn to this yeah i use that on my
kids sometimes
if you guys just tell me no then i'll go
do it isn't it crazy that little moment
it's just a moment that's a moment in
time that just is etched in you and it's
it is the right thing to do yeah yeah so
he lives
with you the entire time he stays with
you guys the entire time so what happens
is my family i'm sorry interrupt but you
get
a good 20 years with them roughly yeah
we get a good 20 years i mean i remember
i was a kid when i was in iran but then
when he lives with us but
here you got them in your house you have
that daily influence of that yeah we've
probably had him for
15 to 20 years wow numbers are right and
and and the fact is
he became again because my mom did not
cook
and then my father so so
in the early 90s so my father would come
to america with all this money loses it
in bad real estate
real estate investments and he's buying
[ __ ] all the time so i don't know trying
to buy the mgm
yeah yeah exactly so um in the early 90s
the iranian government
realizes oh wow we had a kind of a brain
drain as well as a
financial drain a lot of people that
could left so they go look if you had
properties in iran
and you left at the revolution ten years
have gone by
no hard feelings come back and do
business bring your money back here
so a lot of people started going back my
father went back to iran to see if he
could do
something with his old real estate
to try and um spark some business so
he goes so my grandfather kind of acts
as the man of the house at that point
i'm in college at uc berkeley in
northern california
my two younger brothers are home with my
mom so grandpa's kind of like
there to help and assist in any way that
he can but he's also
living his life and he's also this
amazing
influence on all of us i mean he was
like i said he was like the mahatma
gandhi and he was funny and had a sense
of humor
he was sitting around there's a persian
radio station that talks only politics
so he'd just be listening to that all
day and then again once in a while you
just be sitting there and
he would get so worked up you know how
we right now everybody gets worked up
like whether you're on pro trump
anti-trump whatever you've got
[ __ ] that guy [ __ ] the liz whether
people use he'd be sitting there
sometimes listening listening and
listening
in his three-piece suit you know in a
suit yeah
he's sitting there listening to this and
then i'd be like whatever i'd be
you know eating lunch and that you know
over on the on the little dining room
table and all of a sudden he'd be like
may a cow [ __ ] that he just go off and
be like
what he's like he's like going off just
himself
he was the most amazing dude man so yeah
so he was
a big part of our lives and he really i
think
you know um would he come to like any
event you guys had any or sporting
events
it was funny man he wasn't like he
wasn't like if he he was always game for
whatever
so first of all he seemed active that's
why i asked like he would not
he does not seem like a dude that was
sitting in the [ __ ] house he did not
if you say hey we're going he'd be like
let's go yeah
um he would first of all again like he
used to take there was a
santa monica uh farmer's market he used
to take his 50 cents
get on the bus with his he he do [ __ ]
dude he used to sew
this this is actually a great i'm sure
these bags exist now but
there was we used to have you know rice
is a big part of the persian
diet so you get rice in a big burlap
sack
so you take that burlap sack and another
burlap sack and you rip them apart
and then he would spend time sewing them
together now you got one
big burlap sack then we get pillowcases
that are old
sew those on it now you got a flowery
burlap
sack case and he'd take that get on that
bus 50 cents
the bus driver knew him how you doing
pops hey get on that bus go all the way
to santa monica
monica market from from westwood get out
those things up
show up and he they knew him so because
my sister and i followed him around
wants to make a like a
documentary he he'd show up there's
there's these guys mexican dudes that
sell oranges it was actually interesting
because
they don't speak english he doesn't
speak english they know each other
grandpa would show up be like uh i'm i'm
hello hello and you give it to the guy
and they gotta go
got it they would hold his bag and take
that like whatever it is a 10-pound bag
of oranges put it in the bag
while grandpa went shopping get his
other stuff and then he'd come back to
the same place pay them
put everything in his bag and take off
so this dude was doing that all the time
and um it's amazing to me because i feel
like
i think i've rode the bus in this city
since i've been here maybe two times
yeah the metro one or two times you know
yeah never and this is his daily thing
he's finding out schedules
timings he knows where to go in another
country he doesn't speak the language
dude other level i mean it is other
level if you didn't get inspired by that
guy
and that's before internet and gps phone
you know
all the easy [ __ ] no no no yeah he
passed away in 2003. so you gotta
imagine exactly we just said he just got
to
start using that stuff and he was game
for whatever so if you'd be like hey
grandpa like first of all
because we had cars so if you want to go
shopping somewhere else hey give me a
ride i need a ride to go get whatever
um but i remember like i was in the
movie friday after next that came out in
2002 i think
took him to the premiere it was in
westwood had the whole family at the
premiere
he didn't understand a single word he
just sat around
and at the end he was like that was good
i go what'd you get out of me
i don't know but we were laughing so he
was like he sat through a two-hour hour
and a half movie
not understanding anything about it but
just seeing me on there and be like i
had a good time you know
so he was definitely wherever you wanted
to go whatever you wanted my cousin my
cousin from london uh
his name is amir who had a fun
almost like a uh um uh
um um he had a uh uh
what you may call it relationship with
him it was they were kind of um
um what i'm looking for um
like getting into trouble kind of
relationship so my cousin was single at
the time and he'd come visit from london
and he'd be like
he'd take him to strip clubs come on
yeah yeah what cool
strip club and my grandfather's funny
because he'd go there and he'd be like
what's this and my cousin but it's a
strip club and then my grandfather would
be like
oh i don't know if it's nice for these
girls young ladies like he'd feel bad
for him
and he'd be like well we should get out
of here you know but my cousin would
make fun of him a little bit like in a
fun way they'd have fun with it so
he was uh yeah he was he was something
else he was very much enlightened
um there's a there's a poem in persian
that talks about like
surrounding yourself with good people
and it's one
like i i always think of him whenever i
think of that poem it's like it's like
talks about like uh because the the
there's a musk and then burgess it's
like these are like the kind of muds
that people used to put on themselves in
these
in these bath houses and it talks about
like this like someone's at a bath house
and they get a
mud and they go oh my god this mud
smells so good and they ask some mud he
goes are you this kind of
are you this kind of mud or this kind of
mud and the mud goes well i'm just the
regular old mud like i have
i didn't have any of these scents but uh
um i said i was
had like a good influence a flower sat
with me for a day and then i got this
smell
so you compare your grandfather to that
flower you're like that
influence you know helped me a lot to be
who i am
so how active was he in his old like in
his 90s was he still getting out there
and getting around
and stuff really yeah he never really
sort of um
was bedridden or anything like that just
the end of his life so so for me what
was interesting with him was
i always think to myself god if you
could live a life like that again he
didn't he didn't drink he didn't do
drugs
he didn't smoke once in a while he'd
have a drink right drank tea like
all we drink tea all the time he'd have
like three four
you know glasses of tea a day um but
other than that was relatively healthy
go for walks
um like together was he still there
mentally and everything mentally you
know
yeah the only thing he lost was his
hearing sometimes so you'd be like hey
grandpa was like what you know like
that but but and also sight but then he
got uh i mean you know like he got like
cataract surgery or something so he was
fine
he'd read books read books he'd take
notes like he had poems
memorized he knew history he was just
very inspirational like stay active like
my father who lived my father
passed away at 76 and my father used to
say he's like look i'm
i'm in my 70s but i've lived 700 years
like he went hard my father used to
drink he used to do the drugs i did
party
grandpa did not um and and
you know grandpa was able to live until
like at some point in his 90s
you know we're all getting a little
worried he's getting older but he's
still fine he's still active
so he was in his 90s and i think he had
like a um
a gold stone or gallbladder or something
so he had to have an operation
and you know again remarkably he
recovered yeah recovered fine he was
ready to go and so
but like a year or two after that he
had you know we went to see a doctor and
they told us he had colon cancer we
never told him that it was cancer
we just said because mentally he was
still going so we said hey you know that
you don't remember the gulf thing you
had
i mean that's what they say if you live
long enough that's what they say
takes you out in the end anyway in
cancer yeah like if you're fortunate
enough to be that old
yes that's what's going to get you yeah
so he had it and then there was a an
experimental drug that he was taking and
we'd say oh that you're just taking it
for that thing
and he was active until like the last
maybe month of his life and and and in
getting the
because they give you um literature from
the
the the people who uh come from the uh
um
what's it called the uh the
hospice care they come with literature
and they go here's some literature for
you to read to be familiar with what's
going
on and and part of it is they say as the
person
goes to towards like
the dying starts they lose interest in
the things that they like to do
so if the person like to walk up so all
of a sudden they're like i don't want to
go for a walk today or whatever it is
so i started seeing that so all of a
sudden grandpa
whereas grandpa might like nap for an
hour a day he was now napping two hours
a day whereas grandpa used to have
breakfast in the dining room he starts
having breakfast
inside a bedroom or something and then
then his appetite starts going down
and that's when we got i started getting
worried and i used to take him to the
doctor a lot and so we go to the doctor
and we're like because he'd been giving
him this medicine i was i think he was
called as a lota
it was supposed to you know kind of act
like chemo
fight off the the cancer and then the
doctor goes uh
hey again we never told grandpa he's
like i got bad news he's like this is
now
you know um terminal and so that last
couple weeks i remember
did you ever tell him no we never told
him that we just let him
we let him um you know
every day like all of a sudden he'd be
sleeping more he'd be eating less
and be like i'll get some rest don't
worry about it i don't know if in his
mind
he knew but i remember like when i got
the call from the doctor saying this is
terminal i remember calling my
my aunt who's about uh just two years
older than me
my my mom's youngest sister was born
around the same time i was born and so
that was her father and to to her he was
like a god
to all of us he was a guy sure but i
remember calling her and going like
just get some tequila and come over this
is bad news you know we all gathered
around him um
and he was in the living room on the
ground and it was there was actually
a famous persian singer this guy's name
is farah mars aslani and
he is like got a great voice and and his
music is
it's like with guitar kind of acoustic
guitar
because persian pop is like something
else but this guy plays like acoustic
really nice like you don't even need to
know what he's saying to to
to enjoy it and this guy had become a
friend of the family through
some friends and he liked my grandfather
because my grandfather
used to sing this ancient persian style
which is all vocal
and so whenever like any of these
artists would come over my grandfather
would be like let me bend your ears for
me and they would start singing for them
so this guy pharmazlani i'll never
forget like when he heard
the news and some of these guys are so
deep when he heard the news he just came
over
with like a tape recorder and he like
sat next to him and he's like
hey how are you you know i'm here like
you know let's sing a little bit so he's
got him singing like at the end
wow i have no idea where that tape is
right now because i think it was too
painful for me to listen to it again
so were you there for his last breaths
so
this was like the hardest thing i had to
deal with so he
was in a hospice bed in our house we all
gathered around him
and there was highs and lows there was
moments when you know
uh all the grandkids and all of us are
around and like he's laying you know
he's laying down and he's getting
morphine at that
point hospice care comes so he's out of
it but it's taking time
so there was times when we're like we
had like little wigs we put them on put
on the wheels and start dancing and like
laughing and then there was times where
we were sitting around crying um
at one point that cousin of mine that i
told you there was mischievous with my
grandfather he'd come from london and i
was like
i hadn't done stand-up and i was like
okay i got i go i gotta go to the club
because i felt like
having watched guys like richard pryor
and all these other guys talk about
things that were heavy yeah i was like i
gotta go and kind of get this off my
mess i remember going to the club
in the original room my cousin was in
the back and i was just talking about
like yeah i've been home
my grandfather's like passing away and
like you know trying to find
some comedy in there to laugh you know
maybe i don't remember what i said i
might have been talking about the fact
of like
you know it's taking longer than i
thought you know like you know whatever
it was
but that helped me a little bit cope
with it and then i remember
part of it was like all right you wake
up in the morning he's sitting there and
then
you stay as long as you can but then i
was like okay i'm gonna try and
conduct business as i go and i was in
the process of buying this car
so i remember going to this dealer and
i'm sitting there
like you you and i and the dealer's
right there and we're talking
and my phone rings and i answer the
phone and it's my on the the
she goes he passed away oh [ __ ] and i
get in the car i just
rush home and i wasn't there for his
last breath
i don't really regret it because i'm
like you can't live your life that way
can't live your life that way and also
it's like
you were there for all the important
ones i was there uh you know
and and it didn't it it was almost like
too dark at times you know um
and then and then of course my at that
point my mother and my
older aunt were like losing their minds
and crying and screaming and all that
stuff and
and it was actually interesting because
we live in one of those high rises on
wilshire
and people all knew him because he was
always downstairs he was always active
he was always there
so people are coming by to give their
condolences and this one lady comes by
that evening we're trying to keep it
like just family but this lady comes by
and she was this
uh older white lady who was a total
alcoholic like like green-faced
alcoholic
and she had become friends with grandpa
she didn't speak english she didn't
speak farsi i mean she didn't speak
farsi he didn't speak english
but they'd become friends because she
would always see him coming and going so
she comes in she's like i'm so sorry i
was like yeah yeah and she's like
and and we felt bad we're like well you
want to come in come on and she's like
hey i'm not drinking i'm i'm okay i'm
okay
then she saw like there's someone she's
like i'll have a wand
of course right yeah all right and it
was funny because i did i did a joke
once about it because you could send me
even just one
just one right then we went up on the
balcony
and she was like yeah you know he's he
might be gone but he's with us right
she's like you see that star
that's him and it was funny cause i kind
of look at the star and i'm like and
in my mind i'm like oh that star's
moving okay that's an airplane
and i was like hey like you're drunk ass
out
gail's out of here you know she's like
you might want to go to the airport and
pick him up he's gonna be landing soon
ah this has been great dude yeah man
well thank you uh that's a hell of a
story to have an influence like that in
your life i mean lit [ __ ] your life in
your house you had that man in your home
in different worlds and everything i
think that's
awesome for you guys and now you have
those stories for your kids those
memories
yeah yeah man to be to live to be a
hundred in today's world
no yeah i can't the one thing that i did
learn also is like just
be active you know yeah all the time
keep the machine moving
just keep moving i mean even under covet
i've i've had times when
because i'm not touring i'm like all
right well then i'll just do housework
or go for a walk when's the last time
you're able to get actually get outside
and go for walks and breathe some fresh
air
the traffic's dead around here for a
while it's been
i mean that's been at least fortunate we
you know
it could be worse i know this is an
awful weird time but our air could be
poisonous
our water could be you know what i mean
like it's you just gotta keep it [ __ ]
sucks
keep moving in life literally keep
moving yeah
um all right so this is your first time
on the show so i want to ask you now
going back
what advice would you give to your 16
year old self
you know the advice i would give to the
16 year old self is again coming from an
immigrant background
my parents really kind of uh influenced
me to not get into this
comedy world earlier i'd wanted to do
acting and theater and all that stuff i
did in high school and all the teachers
would be like you got what it takes and
and they would like my parents would
come to a show and my the director would
be like your son's really good and my
dad thank you thank you and then in the
car my dad be like don't listen to those
teachers
that [ __ ] is crazy that [ __ ] is crazy
yeah don't listen to me
you're gonna be a lawyer or a doctor
like that's it none of this you guys
that's what i got my dad took me for a
walk once i was like son you'll never be
successful in the entertainment industry
he goes he goes because we're not jewish
i'm like dad really
i certainly said that he's like you know
be a lawyer
i was like oh like they're not jewish
so he um so yeah i and listen
i always try to go i never have regrets
because those
those years when i went to berkeley i
made some great friends i got a chance
to study abroad in italy i
the experience i had was something else
and but i didn't get into stand-up until
i was
until i was 26 and i probably could have
started at like 17 or something
yeah so i go you live once
and that's when i was 26 when i had my
light bulb moment you live one life you
can't live
to impress your parents or for them your
girlfriend
anybody you can't live for anybody else
if you have a passion that you really
love
you got to do it that's it and um and
and don't wait on it either i had a guy
in his 60s his name was joe ryan when i
was
uh you know in my mid-20s i was working
in an ad agency and joe gave me that
advice because i told him i wanted to
save up some money till i was like in my
30s to start trying to pursue this
and he's like listen he goes i'm in my
60s now and he goes there was things i
wanted to do in my 20s
never got around to if you're going to
do it do it and i was like oh my god
lightbulb moment
i read this thing the other day that
going back to that
for especially if you're older the best
time to invest
or plant that tree was 20 years ago the
next best time
is now yeah because in 20 years you're
going to say the same [ __ ] i should have
done it when i was 20. i should have
done it when i was 40. i should have
done that [ __ ] when i was sick
do it do it do it now you're right dude
thank you so much for coming on
thank you ryan please promote everything
again the podcast your social media
yeah atmos giobrany across the board
m-a-z-j-o-b-r-a-n-i
uh youtube channel subscribe um i drop
an episode of uh back to school with
mangia brian every week
uh itunes spotify etc and then my
netflix special is called immigrant
people can check that out
um but yeah follow me uh on the podcast
hit me up if you've got suggestions
ideas i'm always responding so i'm there
you're great dude thank you so much as
always ryan sickler on all social media
ryan sickler.com
we'll talk to you all next week
[Music]
you